I've had the same write programs for quite a while. Should it be changed? Should the programs be
changed? Well, not always. So if there are new frequencies for your type of cancer, would you
send a cheek swab in? Typically, I will update your frequencies, or I will test when I get your
cheek swab, or sometimes if there's new frequencies, I will let you know and send you a flash drive.
So it just depends. So if there's no new frequencies for your particular cancer, and even doing
the cheek swab testing with kinesiology, if nothing else comes up, then no, we don't do any changes.
Even if you've had the same program for a long time, I've had some people writing the same program
for a decade or more, because they're doing well and they're stable and they don't want to change
anything. And sometimes people ask for a change in program because they're stable and they have
other comorbidities that they want to add to their overnight. Maybe hey, could get requests like
hey, could we add blood pressure to my overnight, or could we add neuropathy to my overnight?
Because my cancer is pretty stable, and I just want to start treating these other things without
having to do them during the day. So yeah, we could do that as well. So it just depends on what
your desires are.